ladies and gentlemen welcome another
fantastic episode of your favorite
podcast welcome to
and as usual we got the singing mind
[Music]
so with that anyway welcome to the
podcast ladies and gentlemen very funny
and talented mr. Gary Owen thank you if
there was like people here they would be
welcome Eric tall brother here we go
everybody another person did my podcast
about to blow up with watch this watch
these numbers big Gary Owen influence
yeah um so you know it's funny I'm glad
you on because um it's like it's one of
these things where we know each other
but we don't know each other
right you know like I don't really know
your story I don't know where you're
from I don't know where you know I don't
know where you started I just I've just
have seen you over the years you know
you just that guy you know what I mean
so we're home I don't even know where we
met it's probably a some show or
something like that right well it must
be a Fat Tuesday or something something
black not the mainstream guy I don't
even know anybody the comedy store
I know it's funny when you were there
that time you know I stopped when you
were there and you were kind of walking
around I was thinking to myself man this
is crazy because you've had like such a
tremendous career already and then here
you are just like mainstream club that
like everybody thinks this is where
comedy is and it's like you're not
you're not necessarily there you know
it's just proof that you can make it
into business in any sort of way
yeah I was anonymous with the door guy
yeah yeah because they straights Tommy
yeah viola I wouldn't be walking by like
you have to know who I am yeah I walk by
like oh no he's good because I was like
oh I'm really up Luke that's a dude you
know what just happened to me my parents
just moved to Oxnard so he moved
literally almost across the street from
the the levity live on an Oxnard I never
been there you perform I've performed
there a couple of times but not that
weekend but but I've performed there a
few times I've done like a night I said
that was prepared for a special so they
let me do a night but anyway Shawn
Wayans was there you know and
who do you have out there su Lee was
opening from really silly yeah so su is
that they're selling t-shirts and stuff
and so I go where Sean go say hi to him
so I go to in the club I go to the green
room I'm about to knock on the door when
the security's like a man excuse me you
know you can kinda help you know then
the other guy was there they were like
surrounding me like yo what's up crazy
dude
and then I was like I mean I'm not
saying you're supposed to know who I am
but like you don't know nothing at all
like yeah you know nummy Laden
workaholics nothing you don't saying
like you know and then like Sean you
open the door and Sean's like hey man
what's going on I'll just do like I
can't wait so I'm headlining here
because I'm gonna be talking about this
I don't want a story top you go ahead
but yes you do I got a great one where I
got stopped and almost got banned from
the club off a complete misunderstanding
uh-huh I was at the Columbus funny bone
I'll never forget as long as I live
because it was the night Yao Ming was
playing Shack so Houston was playing the
Lakers for the first time like yeah I
was against Shaq that night that's how
long ago this was right and I'm
literally I'm there in like three months
never been a Columbus funnybone I'm in
Columbus I walk in and I figured out
we'd get stopped at some point I wasn't
like a household name right right right
so the Columbus phone had the front bar
and had these swinging doors to the
showroom yes I walked through the
swinging door expecting to get stopped
like somebody's gonna stop me and I can
a I'm here to come I just want to say hi
and and see what the room look like it's
really always stopping in where to see
what the room look like and I don't even
know who wasn't a big headliner that
night I don't know who was and when I
hit that first swinging door man this
one guy so the escort me out right and
now I go hey man I just I'm coming here
in a couple months I just wanna say hi
the manager I just want to see the club
I said I did not want to see I'm not
trying to get free drinks for free food
yeah so I stood at the bar for a good 15
20 minutes waiting on the manager to
come out right
and the bartender goes who are you again
and I go oh my name's Gary Owen he goes
what do you do I said well I'm coming
here a couple months he goes now I know
you're lying
I booked all the comics the bartender
said that
when I go out so I think I got got a
mango here the bartender I know my
agency is not calling you off appearance
alone I know they're not calling you to
book me
and then the manager comes out and she
says you know and we have a cordial
conversation yeah I said I honestly just
want to see the room yeah I didn't know
this is gonna be this big of a deal if
it is I'll leave so she escorts me into
the the showroom I sit there for five
minutes right take off right I get a
call from my agent money go what
happened at Columbus funnybone I go what
do you mean they go they said you came
the way they made a sound of my agent
was I kicked the door and when your
mother-fucking don't know me you don't
know who I am and I was like dude that
is not what happened yeah and even the
the GM Dave Stroup who owns it Dave yeah
so Dave was the one that called is like
I'm cancelling Garryowen
tell him to get his ego under control my
my agent at the time was Nick nice Ofuro
who is now my current agent that's
what's crazy other's businesses uh-huh
he goes that doesn't sound like Gary at
all so Nick calls that telling what
happened he calls Dave and we get it
worked out so I come a few months later
and when I'm supposed to come right how
was that and it was great Stroupe was
funny he picked me up in the morning for
press I still have been in the club yet
so we have a great day of present he and
I go I mean do you want to dress the
elephant in the car he goes but I wanted
to feel you out first and then when I
tell the story goes okay your story
makes more sense than the story that I
heard yeah and then he's one that told
me because they they made it sound like
you came in and Bruce Lee the door that
makes more sense I go dude literally I
was expected to get stopped but I just
didn't see anybody in the bar to stop
him to stop me so when I opened a
swinging door I figured something about
who are you and then I can tell them who
I am
but but I think it's that guy like yo
like security when I see that there is
no um turnover at that Club it's the
same manager me me big black bouncer
yeah I don't think it was them I think
it was probably the bartender or
somebody else he said he got he got
like three different stories from the
staff whereas my story made the most
sense it kind of tied it all that's what
you do injuries well I don't want a
one-up your story but this is retelling
these type of stories I forgot where I
was
I don't I actually think I was in
Columbus but I get off no because who
doesn't a car pick you up at the airport
used to no long drive up okay so I'm
there I get off the plane and there's a
guy standing with a sign it says Griffin
you know walk over how you doing he goes
like this
me hold on he throws Archie no no if he
goes no no even worse he goes on me you
ain't Eddie Griffin 80 you know Oh cuz
II Griffin yeah oh yeah at this point -
you don't understand though this dude we
would not stop talking about it the
whole way to the hotel
like I'm exhausted you know to me it was
like and he's like man thought it was
Eddie Griffin I was so excited I was
telling everybody I'm picking up Eddie
Griffin and he's just going on and on
about it in this car you know what Eddie
Griffin would have been mad if that was
his driver cuz can you imagine if he was
saying to you how obnoxious he would
have been to Eddie okay not since we're
on it this is great this is just gonna
be segue to sec yeah yeah it's gonna be
like that old HBO show with David Cross
the show mr. show we just went on long
sketch to just win it the other okay so
I'm in Shreveport Louisiana and all the
good rooms I think it was a funny bone
and it was only open for like a year and
I was like I remember that can act in so
when I get there I go there it's not a
huge turnout this is 15 years ago maybe
and there was like a fish tank there was
a it looked like Mardi Gras over here
there was a New Orleans head Saints
helmet there just wouldn't if it was a
honestly was a beautiful room it was
seamless and that's why I said so what
is this
this club and I start going in a little
bit not mean-spirited we're going in
yeah so this is Thursday night I get
offstage there he goes Amy can I talk to
you for a minute he goes man I might be
taking this a little person man but I
built this with my bare hands
oh no me and my guys we built this is
our club man you kind of went in on a
little hard and I go dude I'm kidding
you opened up a comedy club and you're
feeling right it's gonna be a long run
we had a tense weekend and ended okay
right but was it I got through it I said
okay let me not whatever and then I
liked it the schedule and he said Eddie
Griffin's coming then next week and I go
Oh Eddie ain't gonna make it
I heard any after the second night was
done I already got quit I heard they
called the cops on him yeah the [ __ ] and
I was like well I said a lot of stories
all over the country man Eddie yeah yeah
well that club didn't last long I knew
it would I do you're offended at that
I remember that Club you played it yeah
yeah I know exactly what you're talking
about didn't last long
you know I how about this one do you
remember kicks in Detroit mm-hmm oh it
was out of Michigan it was one of these
towns out of Michigan I forgot like it's
like Detroit you got to drive 30 miles
uh-huh but there's a place called kicks
and it was owned by like he was a
Detroit Lions kicker you know oh really
or like or he was like one of them he
was the I think he was the brother of
the guy that that missed all the that
missed a field goal
yes he was a brother that got it missed
a field goal for the bills well they why
they lost the Superbowl not nor was that
Norwood Scott Norwood I think it was his
brother okay they own this plane they
called the place kick so they had this
common club so you were staying at so
you were staying at like the Red Roof
Inn okay
and I can't stand staying at a hotel
where when I open the door is outside
that's not that's a safety hazard yeah
yeah that's our business yeah I don't
want to be like okay so all right just
we get there's a Dunkin Donuts gas
station literally on property that's the
kind of place it was and in the club
complex cuz they had like a a bar you
know the restaurant and they had a club
upstairs type of thing all right it's
6:00 6:30 a.m. I'm about to go to press
or whatever I go downstairs and I say
hey can I get my free
you know you get like a breakfast ya can
go to the ladies like well you don't get
it because the club booked the room okay
so now I'm like I said wait do you
understand that they booked the room for
me like it's I'm here for the room and
she was adamant about like yes but you
know you don't get you know the stuff I
was like it got heated you know what I
mean I mean it got to her you know I was
like you know she was like Gooden have a
nice day and I was like [ __ ] you this
like for Dunkin Donuts this is yeah dude
I now I look back on it I shoulda let it
go but I'm one of my $2.00 it was it was
the principle I was the principle it was
a principle of so I called a manager I
said we have with a problem over a
roofie situation she calls the manager
and then they're going back and forth
and she was like well your Fuhrer your
comedian told my [ __ ] you to my lady
and then the manager was like yes but
she said good morning in a way things
when I finally go back the day they
apologize I'm sorry there was a
misunderstanding
but I was like man is this certificate
for this Dunkin Donuts
that deed that deep did you have to
treat like I'm a customer at the place
there's only like it was come out of her
pocket yeah yeah is it like yeah is this
some kind of bonus the dick cut into the
employee bonus to give out these
doughnuts they only make 16 bavarian
cream by the time i get off yeah there's
two left you ain't getting - laughs - it
was that [ __ ] I've had some horror
stories manatees when people ask you
when you do radio interviews or anything
they always ask you what's your favorite
city and you can't because it varies
club to club in night tonight but you
could tell the worst cities yeah yeah
yeah the worst tell me Evansville
Indiana oh there was a funny bone there
I tell you it was right at the point
where I was I was bubbling a little bit
where I was starting to move a couple
tickets and my kids I could start
demanding a little bit like I could the
rider is real now yeah
hotel right yeah so again she tried to
take me the glady picture for the
airport in Evansville tries to take me
to a Days Inn and it was a [ __ ] Days
Inn and I went on staying here and then
she goes huh I go I'm not staying here I
call him a manager and I'm like and
she's in the car
I go there trying to put me two days in
I said I can leave and then sort of
manager goes hold on we'll take care of
it and then so they they move me to the
Marriott right uh-huh the Marriott sits
right by the airport but it's in a field
literary by itself so now the ladies
heat it like I'm a diva now yeah yeah so
I she tests at Ames in America and I'm
I'm feeling great I'm ready for a great
weekend now I'm comfortable to be
comfortable Marriott's a pretty you know
consistent yeah so she's on her way to
Marriott we get to the Marriott right
and I literally go to her and I'm
thinking we're having a cool
conversation now and I go ma'am I just
listen I have a nice house if I leave my
house I just won't be comfortable yeah
and I'm telling her I want to give you a
good show I said we're gonna have a
great time this week and I'm trying to
defuse it uh-huh
and she seems like she's feeding into it
right she's not the hit I go hey I'm
kind of hungry she goes well if you
would've said the days in there was a
win he's right across the street she was
like see to that and let me go in oh and
this before uber eats I go I'm on my own
I just got to find out what they got at
the Marriott which he didn't upgrade for
the Mira but that whole week at the club
I will never forget it it it it's sat by
it it's sat in a shopping center there
wasn't a kitchen it sat next to not a
subway but like an off subway it was
long sandwiches like poopies or
something like that but like but it was
like they had hot like grinders and sub
sandwiches and that was the kitchen
right oh you did I got I got free food
but my opener didn't and I told him I go
dude I'm probably gonna eat so let me
order it and I get it and he was like
you serious
he's a young kid oh yeah so he was
killing these meatball subs all week
that's what I remember and then there
was one night where nobody laughed the
host went up silence - featuring up
silence I'm about 20 minutes in and
all's it was a bunch of white dudes and
John Dee
hats with flannels enough for their
belly stuck out they could hold the
wrestlers arms as ideas and I just went
hey guys um later the Cable guy's not
walking in man this is it okay if you
came to have a good time and he goes oh
those are big shoes to fill [ __ ]
I just swept I'm done that was the
longest hour of my life silence
I'm still trying to hustle merch
afterwards right who for you so I'm out
there buy my t-shirts and stuff and all
sudden this guy goes I'm it was set so I
had a Boston Celtics warm-up shirt on he
goes well sad I go boss sells warranty
where'd you get it
um let's say uh huh New York so you guys
he goes I want it how much you pay for
it I go 60 bucks I'll give you 80 I went
you took it off today t his girlfriend
comes out and she goes what are you
doing why'd you bet it's true cuz I
wanted it where the [ __ ] am I at I know
man you know I I think that night I made
a hundred dollars of merch I sold one
t-shirt but I sold the shirt off my back
Oh Shh literally selling merch and a
wife-beater like this man I'm telling
you when you when you when that grind
when we're first coming up is like we
did places we stayed at things we have
to do did you ever do the college's
probably before when she started doing
stand-up I started let's say Road grow
dog in it like 2008 yeah this is 10
years for this is 98 yeah my first paid
headlining comedy club was a place
called the comedy stop in Columbus Ohio
and this guy's name was Andrew Ford and
I'll never forget it he put me a member
bopi oh he Hopi yeah we were
co-headlining so it let's say there was
a chose we flip-flopped every of the
show he had line and I had I was two-man
show yeah both in 45 minutes and he had
us in and I didn't know that was section
8 apartments right behind a club with
section 8 apartments the clubs in the
hood right no Jesus I never been on the
road before I thought this is normal
right right right so I go in there and I
get there and I get draw
like 11 a.m. which is seem like just a
little apartment building
then I literally was I out of a movie I
heard people yelling what focus are you
in you know I walked outside once your
brother's just hanging out look at you
like they knew they put the comics there
oh gosh today was literal I owe you the
comedy stop they sued right yeah and
then there was a mall across the street
and that thing shut down now but I
remember me and bopi took a stand
because I think was one of them we got
there Wednesday and the shows were
Thursday through Sunday Saturday comes
morning we're like dude you got to get
this TV working we need cable we're
bored bunking here
no and we took a stand we wouldn't come
over there till we got cable because one
football was starting yeah but I do it
was the first week of college football
and I was like we want to watch football
on Saturday and what was the name of
this place the comedy stop in Columbus
Ohio
so me and Bo people like this we're not
coming over to we get cable basic so you
had to get cable hooked up and then
here's how shady this dude was so the
week's over he goes a man who ever I got
next week backed out he goes can you
stay an extra week I'm gonna be like the
show has been held over by popular
demand Pope he couldn't do it I could
say yeah I'll stay another week so he
said I'm making up numbers
he's like we'll do $1,000 for the
weekend he goes and then add at whatever
three hundred people you get an extra
$500 and then if we sell it out
I'll keep another 500 so you had the
possibility of making an extra thousand
a show or something like that I'm just
making up numbers right dude when I tell
you those shows were packed the next
weekend and granted it was probably a
lot of free tickets regardless but the
deer was bodies in the room because the
comedy clubs make food make money off
the food yeah chili theater which they
don't want to acknowledge right every
Friday and Saturday the four shows two
friends who are packed right something
oh man I made a good decision right huh
I go to settle Sunday night he goes yeah
man the numbers aren't wood I thought so
so he gives me the [ __ ] minimum if it
was $1,000
even I go there's no way dude there's no
way so I go dude and I lied I said I
have my buddy count in the room we hit
some bonuses right he goes let me check
my numbers so he literally went over his
numbers again his I I'll give you I'll
give you two of the bonuses right he had
a safe in the floor he made sure I saw
this he lifts up the carpet uh-huh
there's one of them safes in the ground
does it opens is safe there's a gun on
top of the cash but he just wanted me to
see he had the gun he'll I Gary I'm
gonna give you have like like don't
argue with this now so now I'm looking
like is it worth my life the Rye Rye row
or whatever and so I just took the half
and I never worked with him again and I
I taught when I go to Columbus I talk
about on stay there yeah it's my first
time here I was at the commerce stuff in
the whole kragle and I see the neighbor
and then I say who it was and like
Andrew Ford try to come to the breakfast
club one time it was like Gary was
trying to tarnish my name my name is
impeccable and Columbia's like nah but
he he tried to reopen a comedy club I
want to say like eight years ago
and like you say the hallways you needed
you need a hotel more the hallway right
for example there's a guy named tear a
not dear a tear a he got shot and killed
I almost killed after a show got shot
like four times see this is what I'm
saying they went right to his room and
they right when he was walking in the
room they kind of went in behind him and
then they held him grow up and they shot
him like four times and then took hit he
just got paid from the comedy club and
he had like much money and he had some
jewelry so it clearly was dudes have
followed him or a settle they just know
yeah I was like this you can't dude you
got you we got to have a lobby and
cameras and say yeah I need one of those
things where I got a hit to uh you know
I gotta use my key to get in after 11:30
yeah you know exactly that's a safety
reason yeah I mean this is what a
business that we man I'm just trying to
think of like I've had so many
experiences like that where I like or
like cause like when I if you tell me
like hey house like we comics talk to
each other they go like hey hey my house
that Club I never I'm not asking you how
the shows are I want to know where's the
hotel mm-hmm
manager cool is the manager cool is
there a movie theater nearby is it like
what what's the situation with the press
and all this kind of so that's two real
important things when you're going on
the road
good thing is now you're at a point
where there's so many improv and so many
fun
you're pretty safe with any improv or
funnybone nowadays right right it wasn't
like that like 15 years ago the the some
of the funny bones were some seedy dirty
magic places man or places like remember
um you know and rest his soul
remember what's his name in Kansas City
Stanford Stanford his sons somebody died
he died the owner Craig Craig's dead man
I don't know Craig died yeah dude that's
what I heard I was just there didn't I
but do you want to talk about some shady
[ __ ] that was shady but goddamn they had
good steaks I know but this dude would
pick you up he picked me up in a lotus
in winter yeah
like trying to impress me crazy what do
you think huh woody what do you think
the car you know that is Craig Craig
died yeah hey I'm 6 3 2 you know blowing
pounds yeah [ __ ] we doing in this to the
last car in the winter man and then you
take it to the radio and this dude he
want to talk on a radio you know all he
was a local celebs well stammers is cool
if you're a young comic because the club
was in the bottom floor I mean the
county coves on the second floor yeah
bomb 4 was the club and the bar he might
have had a move you might had not have
done it because he moved you know I was
hurt in the end that he was not paying
the comics he was like like bouncing
checks moving the club from place to
place in the area it was stuff like that
going on all right yeah this was missus
like 16 17 years oh yeah yeah it was
different towards the end yeah once the
improv came in like 10 years ago that
was it yeah on a roast
Bosco went there because I didn't
appreciate like the improv didn't want
to pay what I wanted and he would but
then he was cheating you on the bonuses
yeah the place is packed people standing
it up he's like yeah you didn't hit it
yeah you know you don't realize like you
don't want to be that guy that's got a
every time I think they're gonna be
honest like literally every time I tell
you man and and I was in Phoenix a
couple years ago and this guy
Casey is the manager in Phoenix and I
think he's a diamond in the rough I
think he could easily be an agent you
know what I mean he runs it's so smooth
and got a handle on it and he like a
perfect example for Casey is picked me
up all morning we're doing press I said
a make we uh yeah coffee bean out here
you know I was living in Ohio at the
time we don't have coffee beans and I
want some coffee goes yeah he takes it
of coffee bean and then when he's taking
me to press I realized we were way out
of the way and I went dude did you just
take me like 20 minutes out the way goes
yeah I go dude I could've went to
Starbucks you guys for coffee bean
didn't make no bones about their summers
like nah man it's way out of the way
yeah he did that one oh [ __ ] I didn't
realize it he act like no big deal are
they doing this now yeah just uber over
to the UH no I don't get that over to
the person I'm getting it I'm not a Gary
Owen level I had I've had managers asked
me did I want to drive myself the press
was like no but but you Casey scope he
pulled me in the the mayor's office and
scolded me like a child almost he goes a
man could have talked to you for a
minute and so we said oh everything's
good or he goes he goes never I lead the
room so all everybody there was there's
like three people in all right everybody
left just me and him he goes a man the
[ __ ] are you guys doing
I said what is what the [ __ ] you got
three guys on a row with you man every
night you're leaving the green room and
asking us to get you a water asking us
to get you coffee yeah he goes you guys
just out there right guys is out there
hollering chicks and it's it's party
time right and I got three guys at me so
I'm like I had to pull all three guys
into the room and now I'm big I'm the
bigger a man we got to talk with some
chains going alright here cuz Casey's
like dude you got no bike on the room he
goes and we're not ripping you off but
other clubs will he goes they'll short
you you know I mean go be tornadoes like
we had to 70 not a lot but ten tickets
paid as 10 tickets paid yeah it adds up
over all the shows yeah
that's 100 tickets yeah yeah skimmed
right and I'm not saying all the clubs
do it Casey just went yo you got to just
protect yourself and a lot of times it's
not even what the number is your guys
counting it's just the club sees you
count yeah they're like oh okay so I got
my guys in the room and I was like yo
and I'm going off dude
shit's changing now you count in the
room there's three you whip me I go I
don't care which one is in the green
room just one of you has to be in here
at all times you guys can decide which
one it is I don't care I said but I
can't and it made sense I go why am I
always opening the door yelling for you
guys there's three I know you want a
[ __ ] waitress I get it I'm like this
I know your type so when I get to a club
the guys are no of me I know their types
I'm like I know who you're hitting on
the first night I know who you're locked
in you know what I mean
you like the fat one oh yeah watch out
for this one he's coming you know what I
mean
so I mean it was but I mean Casey's like
he just like open my mind like this oh
[ __ ] you're right there's business we
came across the worst I've ever come
it's Craig Craig whatever his name is I
didna been in Kansas City
yeah just because of just everything
about the whole trip you took me to a
strip club okay but like this was the
most
I don't not a strip club guy me neither
I'm just not a strip club I'll go every
now and then but it really is and people
might you're lying Gary it's sometimes
it's the food when I tell you Magic City
Atlanta has some of the best food I'm
hits all go at lunch there's like some
two strippers of the pole and I'll
literally come white where you at
Medicine eating lunch you're walking
they go
[Music]
cuz I'm not gonna be like I've never
been but I'm not a guy that's like dude
we're just trip club that when I get to
a city I know and there's a lot of
people that are like that just for the
first time I ever went on the road I was
doing Tribble you ever right you ever do
triple runs like just a guy in Montana
and this guy just guys Scott from Utah
he was a headline or you know and like
we had to go to strip clubs oh yeah it
just was like I just cuz I'm Eric
save-a-ho
you know I mean I've always wanted to
pick up a hooker and talk scared I get
arrested I just want to like pick one up
for an hour bag let's go to Denny's what
happened how did you end up man you know
I mean and I always say there's like a
thing called strip club mentality so
like I always say like if you're a dude
all right I don't care how nice you
think you are all right I don't care
what a choirboy you think you are I
don't care what you have your good
intentions the moment you walk through
the threshold of a strip club you are
now a piece of [ __ ] okay
and they see you as a piece of [ __ ] and
the ones they prey on the most are the
nice ones that are not supposed to be
there mm-hmm those are ones they go look
at him he probably got a wife I'm taking
all his money the [ __ ] that I want
to do well you know what I mean so but
anyway just like you know it's a good
thing Eric yeah I'm just saying like
there's uh so krejci we just rip the
worst you know the strip club was so bad
I was the main attraction in there not a
Jiffy Lube but like a like a oil change
place in the parking lot which kind of
makes your money here you never mean so
there you go free free oil change if you
go into the strip club for an hour or
something like that I don't know but it
just was like you know it hopeless to do
from workaholics you know said he's like
everybody was like I was like I'm not
supposed to distract people from titties
you know the hanging ball at all never I
don't know I'll tell you a great strip
club story that was told to me by Alicia
Silverstone
we did a sketch for Funny or Die and so
we're just talking and then she goes
she's you're big in the in like black
people know you and I go yeah and she
goes okay I did a movie called beauty
shop with Queen Latifah and them xie xie
so we shoot in Atlanta
she was so one night all the girls went
to a strip club it was a girls night out
she goes and this one girl was literally
in front of her bent over stripping and
looked at her upside-down and then
popped up went but Lucy she's in the
middle of one of her big moments like so
her head was between her legs and she
looked at her upside down just popped
that win and just hearing Alisha do a
black girl accent made the whole story
it was proper you know and so we go to a
strip club and I'm sitting there and I'm
little lost
she's very earthy least very earthy and
then she goes and then a girl just like
was dancing and she looked over I was
like yeah scary so let me see here so
yeah I know my worst manager whose it
was the guy in Pittsburgh was the worst
at The Improv at the improv is a black
guy
oh don't know his name it's different
now they're different now yeah he he was
so bad that when I would go to
Pittsburgh I say I don't see him he
can't be here oh he can't be in the
building or I can just stay home because
here's what he did that just was just so
low I like and we all have our moments
by like me I'm I'm I try to be polite
and I tip and I try to just you know
make it a nice smooth weekend with
everybody I don't know if you've heard
horror stories about me or not
no I haven't okay well Bryan Callen did
cuz he went on his podcast and said I'm
hard to work with but he apologized he
got that in here
I heard that from one person so I am one
I had a sore throat so I said hey I need
some hot tea oh we don't have tea in a
club I go okay
so let me just die on stage let me just
go horse is that what you're saying so
he goes and brings some hot tea tea bags
and hot water
and he goes all those are from my house
though because the club don't have to
see I brought those from my house and I
go great I'm looking like what yeah and
even like you say press he called and
said does Gary want to drive himself to
press and I go no and then when he
picked me up I was like did you not know
I was coming
the car was so disgusting I was like
dude it's not much to run to the car
wash and just vacuum it out I mean it
was like I was riding like this because
I was like I don't touch nothing right
so that was why he asked me to drive
myself to press obviously then we go to
settle and he goes uh he goes I said hey
man I am first all I'm sorry when I got
there my contract at that time said two
rooms
I had three guys I had two other guys
coming so I called the club and I said I
called him and I said yo see if I can
get three rooms this weekend and then
they called and they said well the the
Marriott sold out but there's a hotel
next door I said don't worry about it my
guys is just double up for the weekend
not a big deal
the day before I get there they said
another room over at the Marriott so
they gave you a room they got they know
they got you a room great I'm thinking I
already said I'm good I'm not paying for
it right right so we go to settle he had
taken the four night charge of the other
hotel room out of my check cuz I'm like
this I go all do no no I told you don't
worry about it
he's yeah man but your conscious is two
rooms and you asked for the third so I
said you know what misunderstanding why
don't we split the cost
I'll take care of two nights you guys
together tonight scuse no no and I go oh
was i dick this weekend and then he goes
he goes what I go why are you doing this
I go it's not coming on your pocket I'm
compromising with you yeah and then he
said dude this what the contract says
right so now I'm like I don't gonna
argue I'll just call my agent and
they'll handle yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what they there for right so then
you know I my contract says
transportation to her from the airport I
drove from cincy to Pittsburgh I tell
him
dude I'm driving back tonight so
the car just pick up my opener who's
always been my opener right right he
just picked him up and taken to the
airport he goes now now your contracts
is you nobody else I go what's it matter
it's a body getting in the car he goes
dude this what the contract says and I
just went I hope I never see you again
and that's how I left the room I just
went I hope I never see you yet just
walked out course your speed on the
drive home it's starting to build now
like this you're like [ __ ] you're late
you're late DeNiro in heat yeah you
could get away with you I gotta go kill
this [ __ ] I gotta go get my slave
[ __ ] man
so uh anyways I called my agent mom and
everything so what they tell me is the
manager before him mm-hmm was ripping
the club off the same way we say
managers can rip us off yeah bacon with
the club oh sure there's it's a cash
business there so imagine I've heard
that I've literally gone to jail we're
gonna club all remember Eric shorts
remember remember Anna in Indianapolis
what's the other club not not crackers
but the Morty's I didn't work I never
you never worked Morty's I got a great
stir about crackers I get and I got a
great story about Morty this is great
we're just having nightmare stories of
riffing with Griffin nightmare reduce
basically I've been headlining for what
twenty-one years you've been at it for
11 these are minor stories in the big
scheme of things you're talking about
working 52 weeks a year we're talking
about five or six stories right yeah
yeah so the the manager before the guy
he was ripping the club off so when he
was doing and I was like his second or
third week of managing he was trying to
go back to the club man look how much
money I saved this he was trying to be
that guy at the expense of me
it was like yeah just happiness at the
expense of yeah well come to find out a
couple weeks later Charlie Murphy God
rest his soul he tried to do some some
this not shady [ __ ] but just just stuff
to not make it comfort for the weak -
Charlie I guess Charlie smoking weed in
the green room he came in there and
literally was like hey you can't be
smoking in here
it's a non-smoking club and you can't be
smoking weed it's illegal in
Pennsylvania Charlie goes so what he's
saying and he was like he gave me
smoking in here
Charlie goes I so
open the door and he goes I eat all
these [ __ ] for the whole
weekend because I guess chili was sold
out a weekend you tell me I'm not going
up cuz you ain't gonna let me smoke a
joint in the [ __ ] green room he goes
either you do that I get to [ __ ] out a
green really low for the rest of weekend
you know what's funny about Charlie
Murphy somebody said somebody said I
asked this one manager I won't say who
you know I was at some Club and I was
like well I said he was talking about
riders and I said what's the craziest
rider you ever gotten he goes let me get
it for you
you know and it was Charlie Murphy you
know and it was like he showed it to me
like this is this is the most bananas
and it was like Newports cigarettes I
thought you meant bananas bananas just
all the stuff that he asked for on his
rider it was just like a lot of like you
know it was like this is the most insane
you know what I mean but Morty's no no
before that I actually knows now the
worst manager III I can remember now
someone worse than Craig it was it was
in Erie Pennsylvania
do you work cities I'd never work yeah
Erie Pennsylvania I go to this club and
you have to be clean all right that's
the first thing they want you to be
clean you know and I hate that because
to me that's a novelty that you should
pay for
I'm not saying right week I don't want
to do it or we can't do it all I'm
saying is that's like I'm juggling while
I'm you know I'm doing my act it's a
specialty thing you don't I mean yeah so
like you know anyways so you know yeah
alright as I'm there he goes hey man we
got this special corporate gig if you
want a cat cat make a little bit extra
money you know it's like to want it out
whatever it is like that and I'm
thinking I sell the guy you know for
something like this
this isn't really the kind of money you
make for something like this but I guess
I'm in town you know so now it's time to
go to the airport at the end of the week
and his wife is nice Shay took me to
breakfast for the when we go to the
press but like I said hey um that that
Airport ride you know you he's supposed
to give me money for the airport you
know to and from you he goes like this
he already made extra money and my wife
took you to breakfast you're good
I mean brothers you could you could you
know I thought to myself oh my god never
went back you know I just never went
back it's just one of those moments
where I'm just like what are you talking
about you know oh my god yeah you want
this corporate gig and in his mind's eye
it's gonna get me out uh give me I have
this twenty dollars that I have to
that's the thing it's always the little
money little money it's never the big
money it's when you're first but it's
it's honestly it was me it makes podcast
entertaining yeah yeah it's these great
stories that we can share Morty's
nightmare telling about Morty so it's
when it first opened up so like I was
leaving a headlining yet it was like
what's it's got what I forgot to guy his
first name but his last name was Berman
he was the headliner something Berman
Jim Todd kind of feel bad that I forgot
his name cuz he I don't think he's been
doing comedy anymore but you know he was
a headliner but at that time you had to
do Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday it was a job you know
what I mean it was like nine shows for
like you know I'm featuring so it's no
money so the guy calls me before Eric
shorts was his name he can he was from
LA and he moved it out there black dude
he had dreads short dude he calls he
sends me an email and he says hey man I
hope it's not a problem but she's gonna
be sharing a room with the the with the
host at a hotel room a hotel or a hotel
room yeah it's a big problem Gary Gary
that opened the email with oh it's a
problem I said look man I don't know him
yeah how you gonna have me share a room
with someone this in a summer party we
share in the bathroom we should I don't
know his sleeping patterns maybe I
watched to you you don't do that he
wrote me back
you know you la comics just bright okay
let me give you the guilt trip guilt me
you mean like you're looking at the
crowd and it's like okay so you know can
I guilt you with all this money you make
in with the drinks and the food that
you're not kicking
for this $100 a show that I'm making or
whatever [ __ ] where half the money
has to go to the ticket to get here I
mean it's a nice share the room no cut
to yeah it was a king bed and he was on
the other side I was like early on I was
like I realize you have to fight for
yourself well you know what's crazy is
talk about a bad hotel situation this
podcast is gonna be sound like I
complain about everything oh we're not
but they're great stories man yes they
are good so I did a run to Japan and
military bases and I already expect that
it's not gonna be the greatest
accommodations on the bases this one
base right by Mount Fuji US Marine base
but it was more of a transition base so
it literally was guys coming or going
into the [ __ ] from Japan right oh wow so
the I mean it was some it was tense
right the guys are a little tense they
told us I've done something they're
gonna let loose if they like you they're
really gonna laugh they go and they're
gonna be drunk so you might get some
rowdiness they warned us like just no
and we get to this this hotel on the
base barracks on what it was it was no
air conditioning it was so hot the room
look like nothing had been changed since
85 right I said I can't stay here I told
the promoter was in his name's Daniel do
gar you know do gar from the Bay Area
yes so I tell do gar I go do gar he's
the promoter spooker and he's also the
host right right right but this is his
[ __ ] right and I'm very I'm you know I
like Daniel II trying to guilt you with
that it's for the military yeah well
this what he did and Arizona makes the
story good so I literally go the front
desk I don't speak Japanese I love you
that I asked the Japanese guy go
I need Hotel my cell phone is a calling
of a hotel and Mount Fuji Japan where is
that right so the guy lets me use his
phone he dials it they don't speak
English this guy Lee sees what we're
gonna so he booked me the room so I
catch a cab I go to the hotel it was
great
the hotel was great I tell Daniel I'm
not gonna say Amen I got a room
I'm leaving what time you need me back
for the show so let's say 7 o'clock he
looks like this man you know what I mean
and so I can tell his tents I get to the
show and we meet him a Ronnie Perry
you're sitting there Ronnie's trying to
be over Ron he's trying to be the buffer
right it's so tense to me and Daniel and
Daniel start do girls call me Mariah
Carey right G boom right Carey and he
goes he goes 8 and he did it he's guys
right here dying for us they ain't
complained about the accommodations I
said I'm stopped right there yeah I was
like these guys are 19 20 years old I
said I was in the military was you I go
when I was 19 and 20 I didn't care where
I stayed I stay anywhere I said
hopefully these guys make the right
decisions in life that when they get 40
they can state a nice hotel and not feel
guilty about it
that means they live the right life they
did the right things in life I go I
don't feel guilty at all because I've
stated [ __ ] like this before right now
and then so the show's over I just got
in a cab and headed back to hotel I
wasn't trying to argue with Daniel or
anything right so that night I slept
great
I got up early I got a Japanese
breakfast on a wood [ __ ] I ate right
so Daniel Ronnie now have to pick me up
at the hotel and I know that these
companies is a shitty so I'm cured up
for an argument I'm okay I'm ready do
this man you know I got I got my
comebacks ready okay I get in the van
and I'm ready to go right I'm do girls
amen um you were right
he literally like this you you were
right those accommodations just terrible
I gave you a hard time but and Ronnie's
like it was hot
Ron deviant right and I yeah a man I
just said you were right I went oh yeah
you're right just said amen
you were wrong those accommodations were
terrible he had already defuse it and
everything I mean I hate to feel like we
just bitching about stuff but it's just
random stories like I said 52 weeks of
the years mostly great a lot of the
clubs are great you know the man
grade their accommodations are great but
that's why when they're not it stands
out it's like having a bad set yeah yeah
yeah you'd be like you you have great
sets but when you do bad
you remember those yes you know we're
not gonna talk about that yeah this
podcast will be over we've been talking
for so long already I love this but I do
want to get a little bit like you know
I've watched you for a long time I don't
remember where we met but I'd like you
say it was probably at like tripping on
Tuesday or yeah or you know I remember
well I do remember first time I saw you
live was at tripping on Tuesday and uh
some I said yo this guy's funny though
he's different so I watched your set and
it was it was some about Jesus yeah yeah
and I was just I I like comedy that when
you don't see it coming from whatever
their whatever the direction it is I'm
like and I don't watch the last stand up
I'm very I stop I can't watch an hour
somebody I just hung it and then I can't
I can't go to comedy concerts and I'm
just like I get so bored cuz you see a
mic in a stage and in a captive audience
you want to be on the stage yeah yeah
and I and also so you don't enjoy comedy
anymore not watching it not a lot I
watched your special and text you yeah
and I think I watch that on the plane
yeah yeah this is one of those things
you're layering your soul to Yes Mother
but here's the thing I'm watching your
one special at the Long Beach laughter
yeah and it had to be two shows you
edited it down to one show yeah yeah
there was if you watch there's two white
girls laugh I go no that was great the
only thing when you do a special in a
small environment that's what happens
yeah but at the same point just like I
mean people get it you know I was
cracking up at that you know I know but
that was a great special and and like I
said I I always want to know that that
my jokes are mine
because I've seen comics they don't
necessarily take jokes but they take
mannerisms they start moving like
somebody else things like my opener now
is a Cambodian dude names say home or M
say M right and he literally will start
like talking like me and I like say
watch it you're starting to turn into me
you don't realize it cuz you around me
so much yeah things like didn't realize
it the funniest [ __ ] though was I had an
airplane joke and on my airplane joke
one of the setups is the seat numbers 32
be there this will [ __ ] to the
airplane Joe and he goes yes I didn't
like the guy in the back was in 32p and
I went did you take the [ __ ] seat
number bro he goes oh my god did I say
that again
he was probably cuz I heard you say it
so much on your brain you know what I do
remember that day that you will you saw
me at the Comedy Store you know why cuz
you said to me you said funny set man
it's gonna be funny when I do it like
you know I feel like you got to come
back on because it's like I really
wanted to get into all kinds of other
stuff but this has been fun though it
the way it is but it's like you know you
are the you know you have been the white
comic who plays all the black rooms yeah
you know and it was on the karl malone
comedy and there's just like you know
it's like has that been a stigma no I
mean I always say you you don't choose
your audience they seem right right it's
just the first time I got on TV was was
beads he's come to you they never came
the host and then that's right and then
and that was the dark years to those but
if it's like I was on a treadmill for a
long time I'm saying from like I bet you
from like 2003 to 2011 or ten I was like
just run in place I was headlining
making decent money my ticket sales
weren't going up and they were just like
I kind of
knew what I was gonna make every week
right and then uh I opened up for Mike
Epps in Houston in April 2010 and the
next like Monday they called Mike his
people called me as like you know Mike's
doing this thing called live from the
Nokia and he wants you be on it and I go
okay how much and everything and they're
like I'll never forget they got was it's
not a lot cuz you know this is new so
it's $2,500 mm-hmm I don't live in LA so
I gotta fly myself there I gotta put
myself up and and get to him from the
venue and I was like oh I was supposed
to be in Columbia South Carolina that
weekend and I'm canceled on a weeks
notice and all they said was a Jeff
cleaning ain't gonna be there cuz
Clanton was the one that was doing the
Shaq all-star Comedy jams and he wasn't
from that familiar with me I said if you
guys can promise me he watches my set
I'll do it that's all I asked just don't
let him get distracted make sure he
watches promise great so I get there a
lot of people know don't know about life
of the Nokia there was like 10 comics on
the show and they told us they go only
six are gonna make the DVD so if you're
not on if you didn't make it that's just
because what's funny I don't know if it
wasn't funny or you wasn't funny they we
six yeah yeah I had a headline in it I
was going last and then when it when it
posted I went last so it was one of
those things where I got off stage and
the hair started staying up with the
back of my neck like oh [ __ ] that was a
perfect 20 minutes oh you just felt
great about it like in your bones you
feel like something changed the energy
like the universe kind of shifted a
little bit and I went all [ __ ] that was
a perfect 20 and the first joke was off
the dome not planned because Morris
Chestnut was in the audience
and I go oh [ __ ] more stress and I go
hey he had watch boys and a whole thing
and he's gonna change and I go you be
thinking Ricky might live room for like
don't go down the alley
they're coming Morris in a small car and
the crowd is like lost it and that's the
first time I did the black/white Church
bit and there was like three solid bits
that were like signature bits
yeah it just stuck out and as
20 minutes was like perfect so I get off
in cleaning goes a man was good 20 and
he's talking to him for a long time an
agreement afterwards and then they sent
me to Okinawa to do a military base Oh
with the Shack all started
oh sweet shirt and Jeff said I want to
see him I want to see him overseas first
tell me how he does some tell me has to
work with so there's a girl named Tamara
Goines who now works at innovative I
know Tamara I was at innovative for sex
oh really yeah yeah so while she was
there I left what you know Tamara was
like the girl yeah they took care of the
comic so she was in Japan she reported
back to Jeff said I was good Maisie no
I'm on the Shaq tour and and then right
when I get on the Shaq tour and they're
gonna do my show they're gonna do a
Showtime special they did the one called
true story for me right I get Think Like
a Man all within like a nine-month
period and I'll never forget April 2010
I went oh [ __ ] and then the numbers
start going up yeah yeah and everything
just kind of from there that was like
cuz it was no and then I guess there was
no idea in your in your mind at that
point cuz I guess being in it you
weren't thinking to yourself I probably
should be trying to get white people
here that wasn't even a thought process
I'm just like I'm having people in the
room my job is no matter if you're white
or black it's to bring you into my world
and make you feel comfortable
yeah so I'm still gonna talk about my
wife's black the kids are mixed there's
been times I went on stage and I'll even
bring a race and could a lot of you be
like oh he was told but was black white
black kids you know your people on the
internet says stuff and I'll be like so
I'll let her be like watch this and I'll
there was I did a showcase in LA one
time and I manager was there and it was
a new wave that was the agency the
management company yeah yeah and I went
onstage and the guy goes she didn't do
any black white [ __ ] and I go yeah I
know because I was looking in the
audience there was no black people there
yeah and then he goes that was crazy cuz
you're talking about your wife he goes
in in my brain I had a black woman
pictured but you never said she was
black and I all the times I noticed that
when people like me all you do talk
about let you your black wife I go no no
I say my wife's black and then that's
what's in your brain when I say man
husband wife [ __ ] your
picture in a black woman but I'm not
saying my black wife the whole show oh
yeah my wife does it wife does yeah she
don't do this and you know she ain't
suckin dick like he used to yeah yeah in
your brain yeah black woman yeah but I'm
not saying black wife you know I just
have it ever audience I know I can tell
but I realized that you're not the one
with the problem it's everybody else
that has their perception of what they
want it to be and it's not it's not yeah
it's not even like and you're so white
white too that's the other thing about
yeah and black lamb you don't have the
problem right I never have issues I mean
you always got the internet trolls but
I'm sorry about live and and just
walking around the streets but I'll have
no problems with me at all mm-hmm and
it's always like like like white people
that get offended and doesn't happen a
lot when it does it's white people you
know are people outside the circle yeah
like why are you mad about yeah what are
you mad about
nobody else is yeah yeah I like to say I
know how I know how far to push the
envelope without going too far I'm never
gonna do oh Michael Richards right just
won't happen you know I mean right right
you've all yeah you know it's funny I've
never heard that about you like I've
never been like you know you know Gary
said this one night you know you know
that was today and that's the time that
in the middle of a killer set where the
whole crowds gonna go it's not like like
I've thought about just I just I don't
know it's just like a $0.07 like you
know no don't go there
yeah worth it yes yeah it's not your
fault this is your crowd this is your
audience and you know they love you for
it and look at you you're doing your
thing you know it's it's it's been
successful in us continue to go maybe
we're we're in the kind of business that
it doesn't stop there's no end we're
just looking for the next thing
yeah but it's funny how like when you
say go the comedy store and I'm I'm kind
of like a Bigfoot like they're sightings
of me but it's funny out of it how I
remember that day remember that day you
were there and I was like really I was
no but I was really thinking about it
like damn like you really should be in
here and I understand that it's just
like one of those weird like II just
it's just you just bypassed that part of
the come-up
yeah you know that lets me know like
it's funny how even though I'm doing
gray on the road and the cell intake is
everything like there are some about the
Bryan Callen thing which is funny I
really want to do their podcast
fine idea yeah because of it I was
listening to podcast before that and
Brendan and Kalin when he said that name
Cal took it back because I don't know
why I said that
and and then Brian or Brendan was like
yeah I think that guy had a Showtime
special once once I went that's what
they gonna say by him like yeah like
those guys have no idea dude but when I
go to New York I feel like that like
when I go to New York I'm not in with
the seller people yeah I'm not that's
not gone I've talked to Etsy one time
I'm sitting there with her and she was
like you know if you're in town hit me
up for spots I tried to email her one
time I can't come to New York nothing
now you send me a clip and I'm like it's
like okay here's a clip from my special
that's on TV it's like but it doesn't
matter I know from being at The Comedy
Store they nobody cares nobody cares
what your credits are what you do this
about being in like a certain community
and how you ingratiate yourself into
that community is really what it's about
so but I heard the Comedy Store is dope
now I got her like from what it used to
be all right now like it's very
supportive and it is but it's like it's
still like a clicky it's still click yes
yeah there's a clicks yes click yeah
it's not just one click if I get a bunch
of these clicks very much like you know
high school super nerds those are the
podcasters yeah those are the famous
people I'm the guy that moves that high
school and like was there for like a
couple months right what happened that
dude oh he's homeschooled now yeah you
homeschool yeah we had like a boy's home
at my school so it's funny like we
didn't know we had very few black kids
in my school but every time you get in
the paper and somebody gets in trouble
in the towns around us we got a black
guy coming I came a black guy got in
trouble another school go we got a black
guy coming so you didn't grow up around
black people mm-hmm so when did it
when did it click military well I don't
say that because one of my best friend's
is was was a black guy he moved to my
school in tenth grade and we were really
like he was like my boy mm-hmm and I
remember II had a Rastafarian on and I
know the what it meant it's a cool neck
can I wear it he goes no you can't I go
why not
and I he gave it to me one night at a
school dance I'm walking around that was
the first time people win look at this
dude all right they had like a heart and
some kind of African colors on or
something man like say this I like it so
probably if there were more black people
around in your high school you probably
would have connected yeah well you know
it's that and then I don't want a name
drop but I will I had a development day
with Quincy Jones like 18 years ago 19
years ago and it was it was it was one
of the best experience ever had even the
TV show didn't go anywhere but I always
got to go to his house and talk and it
was like Fiera pee sessions because
Quincy's very much and uh were you from
and how did you end up like black people
and all those other stuff so we really
started just talking and opened up and I
go well um you know I never had any
issues with black guys growing up I go
the white men in my life was awful my
stepdads just an awful human being gosh
she felt like that and I go but I had a
guy that used to babysit me and he was a
black dude they work with my mom and I
go I would go to his apartment and he
had like he had all girls and so it was
like three girls his wife and him and I
just remember like they wouldn't make me
eat food that I didn't like like they
made like peas and corn one time I go I
like peas don't read them let me go mama
he oh my Peas mama he like peas why like
cream qua will give us backs cream corn
in itself and then we went to the pool
they live in apartment building right
and the boobs won them pools in the
middle yeah and I remember I jumped in
I'm like six years old I'm swimmin I go
dying mama he swim good this is amazing
this is what it was and so my viewers
formative years yeah thank that dude his
name was Sonny
[ __ ] man and I used to talk about there
was an ice cream truck driver I used to
drive to the trailer park to black dude
and I've always said on my act his name
was Sonny but it was like a hybrid god
don't really remember his name but I do
remember he was cool and he looked like
Sonny
they both had like the small froze like
the the Lionel Jefferson Oh
dignified yeah yeah and so I made it
like a hybrid and then he was so cool
all the kids in the trailer park the ice
cream truck driver man if he was short
you [ __ ] and him crazy part his
daughters would be an ice cream truck
jar with them so I was like every time I
saw that the two black guys that I would
say adults that I was in contact with
and my formative years was to do the
babysat me uh-huh and then the ice cream
truck driver and they were good dads
there you go
you know I mean yes so the stereotypes
never connected with me and my stepdad
is every bad black stereotype black guys
are ladies I'm like but he's white he's
why when I hear black guys like rods
[ __ ] lazy you know black dog no wrong
[ __ ] you talking about yeah yeah so I
think in in my brain I was very
trustworthy of black men especially
grown up like wow I trusted them
yeah you just really yeah that's just
come even like women because my my first
grade teacher was a black lady uh-huh
and then my second grade teacher was a
black lady and my third grade teacher
visibly and this is why this is eight
why you married 11 now what was hell
okay mrs. lucky was second grade mrs.
eighths was third grade what the hell
was my my first grade teachers in god
damn it
I can't remember but they were all nice
to me well Miss lucky was coming up she
was kind of rough but Miss eighths and
my first grade year they were great
that's amazing like all the best
influences in your life although all the
ones that had a major impact on your
life that stayed with you and touched
you they were all black people you know
your teachers the ice cream truck guy
your yeah the baby it's like it's crazy
so I'm not surprised then you know then
I gravitated you gravitated towards that
nieminen realizes probably yeah and and
even when I got in the Navy I was 17 my
bunkmates name was Cole pare Washington
from South Carolina and he got some
pictures mail from home he was like on a
John Deere tractor
he was on a farm ergo is is you on
vacation he's not master where I live I
go live on farms I've heard the Midwest
but if you live in the cities right man
he called his brother from Alabama's
brother for Mississippi's brother and
George Geary tell what you just told me
I go let me live on farms and it was
like I do the right thing they ever went
from the country I go what the [ __ ]
bill hey so now remember conversations
because in the summertime I worked on
farms I worked on a strawberry farm at
pick strawberries one year and then I
bailed hay and I was a I was a this
sounds bad I was doing a sheep co-op I
took care of eight sheep one summer
sheer dumb walked them fed oh wow you
know I was in future I was in FFA in
high school Future Farmers of America
dang and and so it's just funny because
now I'm sitting here talking this black
guy about farming stuff right
uh and boot camp and I that was my duty
took care of me I felt and I felt so bad
because he really taught me how to make
my bed which sounds simple he taught me
how to fold the clothes right make my
bed he was like he's like Forrest and
and bubblegum yeah like gerbils bubble
gum but he was like he just showed me
everything I'll never forget the last
inspection you know which in hindsight
when a big deal nobody got rolled back
nobody get kicked out but he got in
trouble for some reason he didn't
[ __ ] make his bed right cuz they take
the ruler out and everything real I just
remember like they said Gary and I
helped him make his bed and he helped me
make my where buck mates we're not
supposed to but if you ain't trying and
run right and I'll never forget I was
thinking was it my fault that his bunk
wasn't made right because you know he's
on the right side I'm gonna left we're
just make the sheets in a hospital
cordon everything I just remember I walk
they go you're good on I passed the
inspection I walked into this room and I
look back and I forged eat well they
were called company commanders like Joe
instructors right here they they just
swarmed Khepera and they was all right
here to yell down and over he would just
stand there looking at me like I was I
was like what did you do to my corners
literally I want to come back like
but in hindsight we both graduate on
time they give his all mind game yeah
yeah but at that moment I was like oh
[ __ ] I remember like I was like
literally I had a headache para and what
what branch of the military Navy you're
in the Navy I was like when I got into
Washington [ __ ] and then afterwards I
was like good I'm center part about it
man no big deal was my fault he was so
like it was always his fault not a big
deal my stepfather was Navy Reserve 30
years oh really
yeah I always say like the Navy guys we
don't deserve those homecomings that you
see at the football games of basketball
games because Marines and army they're
on the front line they're in the [ __ ]
there's bullets whizzing by their head
they could step on a landmine they could
die Navy guys were on [ __ ] ship in
the middle of ocean we're playing
dominoes on Tuesday there's space to
around Thursday there's movie night you
got almost made oh if you're gonna have
Captain Crunch and you can gain weight
during war you didn't go to war when you
go back 15 pounds heavier that you
didn't go to war player
yeah Captain Crunch for breakfast I went
to where did I go I didn't go to like
Afghanistan or anyplace scared what to
like Kosovo or Sarajevo or someplace
yeah then like it was it was like it
wasn't USO it was the MWR department and
WR yeah we're out welfare information so
I went to like I remember it was during
World Cup and it was like we weren't we
weren't an e4 base you know the your and
I like those bases better what's it for
me it's the European base okay enforces
okay had this American bases they were
about to close down and so that and then
so we went over to the you know II for
base because they had the US troops
there too but it was like this you know
you had all the different that you know
like France had all these different
places and I remember that World Cup it
was I think it was Italy vs. France in
that World Cup you know so that those
troops are on you know they were alive
with each other oh wow you know but I
remember doing a look like a little it
wasn't a lot of American troops but I
did a little set and I did the delete
they were all from Texas they were all
Texas Rangers you know in this
particular place and and the lead guy
was this black guy from Texas and he
came in late to the show
and I just was giving it to him and all
of the troops ah I just loved it they
gonna cos finally somebody's getting on
this case yeah but I just remember that
military experiences like they just
loved like you know you just sit with
them at lunch and just talk about what's
going on at home and just just be have a
little piece of ya a little piece of
home you know but it was like you know
it's strange because only on the US base
they have to carry guns at all times
hmm over there but on the you another
base you know didn't there was beer
there wasn't no any alcohol in that okay
it's just strong ass coffee yeah I
remember they had like I said really
strong strong you know [ __ ] you
know it's like that kind of like you
know but I'm glad that's it I think that
you can get the military led to your
work ethic like you know oh yeah there
we got into like everything it helped
tremendously I mean it helped for where
I came from in a trailer park in Ohio so
too
so where I'm at I was like yeah
definitely help because I always said
like growing up like I didn't know what
I wanted where I wanted to go I just
know I didn't want to be mmm I don't
wanna be stuck in a trailer park my
whole life and at that time I was like
how do I get out I tried to run away my
junior high school and my buddy Derek
Callahan I remember I go I told him I go
take me to the bus station I'm gonna go
to LA I'll make it I'm funny he was like
this he goes hi I got I'm funny I'll
make it and then I stopped and got
goober grape the peanut butter jelly
mixed a loaf of bread you like and I had
a thermos and I go okay I'll just drink
water from the drinking fountain I know
everyone gently took it to LA I'll make
it that's a loaf of bread and I figured
I was gonna get me and we went down to
the bus station and we had like 13 bucks
between us there's eating it to
Louisville [ __ ] well you know what you
did it look at you who want a long way
from the trailer parking here you are so
what's coming up next you got anything
in the pipeline um yeah I got I just
taped my next Showtime special I taped
it three weeks ago in San Antonio it's
log doing what I do Wednesday I come out
they just gave me
a fourth quarter of this year seeing the
October November December all right so
look for that uh I got two films ones
Undercover Brother - mmm but Eddie
Griffin's not in this one
no Michael Jai White's the lead oh wow
he's like a cool undercover it's almost
like I'm dolomite almost yeah yeah and
then meet the blacks - oh wait we just
got pushed to February that we're coming
out like History Month but that's
actually a funny roll man because I play
a paraplegic ex war veteran avid Trump
supporter that lives in a black
neighborhood and I don't take no [ __ ]
off either any of the people in the
neighborhood got this badass Instagram
model wife Jenna froome's she's like
that chick on the internet right and
she's my wife
so they're always the guys always coming
over to hang out to see her plant the
garden that's dope man
I'm glad you listen you doing well I'm
glad you I really appreciate you coming
on my podcast a podcast is just cash tag
gets them I'm gonna have all of the I'm
on the look if you look in the
description you're gonna see all that
stuff every place you can find Gary it's
gonna be right there and sir I look I
thank you for coming on this was great I
mean we should call this one [ __ ] in
with Griff I know not riffing with
Griffin singing my [ __ ] how can I read
the end in Gary and get to [ __ ] with
Griffin [ __ ] Jim
and Gary like a radio show you know
booboo in the morning I hate doing
morning radio but anyway um this has
been Gary Owen and once again guys
thanks for watching and please subscribe
and like and share make sure you go
check out all of Gary's links and go
check out his podcast and I really
appreciate you coming on sir and I
appreciate you guys watching and see you
guys next week